The world we live in Phil's normal,
ordinary.
It feels like this is just how
humans exist and always existed,
but it's not.
Never before have we humans lived in a
world as sophisticated and engineered to
our needs as today,
giving us the luxury to forget about
ourselves and not worry about survival,
food, shelter, security. All of this
is more or less taken for granted,
but we're a special few.
For more than 99.99% of human history,
life was completely different and
there's no such thing as just one human
history.
Our story begins the 6 million years
ago when the tribe of Khomeini split and
our relationship with the apes
and lit 2.8 billion years ago,
the genus of homer,
the first humans emerged.
We like to think of ourselves as the only
humans, but this is far from the truth.
When we homo Sapien sapiens came
into existence 200,000 years ago,
there were at least six other human
species around cousins of comparable
intelligence and ability,
which must have been incredibly scary,
kind of like living with aliens.
Some of them were very successful.
Homo Erectus, for example,
survived for 2 million years,
10 times longer than
modern humans have existed.
The last of the other humans
disappeared around 10,000 years ago.
We don't know what caused them to die out.
Modern humans have at least a few percent
of neanderthal and other human DNA,
so there was some mixing,
but certainly not enough to
be a merger between species.
So we don't know if our cousins went
away because they lost the battle over
resources or because of a
series of minor genocides.
Either way only we remain back to the
beginnings of humanity 2.8 million years
ago.
Early humans use tools but did not make
a lot of progress for nearly 2 million
years until they learned to control fire.
Fire meant cooking,
which made food more nutritious,
which contributed to the
development of our brain.
It also produced light and warmth
who'd made days longer and winters less
gruesome. On top of that, it
not only scared predators away,
it could also be used for hunting a
torched word or grassland provided small
animals,
nuts and tubers that were pre
roasted from 300,000 years ago.
Most of the different human species
lived in small hunter gatherer societies.
They had fire, wood and stone
tools planned for the future,
buried their dad and had
cultures have their own,
but most importantly they spoke to
each other probably in a kind of proto
language, less complex and
ours. If we had a time machine,
how would we be able to go back,
steal a few babies and raise them today
without anyone noticing that they're a
bit different?
There is much debate anatomically
modern humans emerged 200,000 years ago,
but probably 70,000 years as far as we
could travel back and still snatch a
behaviorally modern human.
Before that,
the babies would probably
lack a few crucial gene
mutations necessary to build a
brain with modern language and abstract.
Thinking about it is at some
point around 50,000 years ago,
there was an explosion in innovation tools
and weapons became more sophisticated
and culture quickpay more complex
because at this point humans had a
multipurpose brain and a more advanced
language to communicate information with
each other effectively and
down to the last detail.
This allowed much closer corporation and
is what really makes us different from
any other creature on earth,
not our comparatively weak
bodies and inferior senses,
but the ability to cooperate flexibly
in large groups, unlike for example,
Richard beehives or intimate
but tiny wolf packs.
As our brain evolves,
we became able to do something life
had been unable to do up to this point.
One,
expand knowledge quickly to preserve
the knowledge gained over generations.
Three, build on past knowledge
to gain even deeper insights.
This seems daft,
but until then,
information had to be passed on
from generation to generation,
mostly through genetics,
which is not efficient still
for the next 40,000 years,
human life remained more or less the same.
There was little to build upon.
Our ancestors were only one animal
among many building a skyscraper.
Without knowing what a house is is hard,
but one,
it's easy to be arrogant in our attitude
to our ancestors. This will be ignorant.
Humans 50,000 years ago
were survival specialists.
They had a detailed mental
map of their territory.
Their senses were fine
tuned to the environment.
They knew and memorized a great amount
of information about plants and animals.
They could make complicated tools that
required years of careful training and
very fine motor skills. Their bodies
compared to our athletes today,
just because of their daily routines
and they lived a rich social life within
their tribe.
Survival required so many skills that
the average brain volume of early modern
humans might even have been bigger
than it is today. As a group,
we know more today, but as individuals,
our ancestors were superior to us,
but then around 12,000 years
ago in multiple locations,
humans developed agriculture.
Everything changed very quickly before
survival as a hunter and foraging
required superb physical and mental,
but it is in all fields from everybody.
With the rise of the agricultural age,
individuals could increasingly rely
on the skills of others for survival.
This meant that some of
them could specialize. Maybe
they worked on better tools,
maybe they took time to breed more
resistant crops or better livestock.
Maybe they started inventing things as
farming got more and more efficient.
What we call civilization
began agriculture gave us
a reliable and predictable
food source,
which allowed humans to hoard food
on a large scale for the first time,
which is much easier to do with grains.
The meat,
the food stock required protection,
which led to communities living
together in tighter spaces. First,
early defense structures were built.
The need for organization grew.
The more organized we got,
the faster things became efficient.
Villages became cities.
Cities became kingdoms.
Kingdoms became empires.
Connections between humans exploded,
which led to opportunities to exchange
knowledge. Progress became exponential.
About 500 years ago, the scientific
revolution began. Mathematics, physics,
astronomy, biology, and
chemistry transformed
everything we thought. We knew.
The industrial revolution followed soon
after laying the foundation for the
modern world.
As our overall efficiency
grew exponentially more
people could spend their
lifetime contributing to the progress
of humanity. Revolutions kept happening.
The invention of the computer,
its evolution into a medium.
We all use on a daily basis and the
rise of the Internet shaped how wild.
It's hard to grasp how
fast all of a habit.
It's been about 125,000 generations
since the emergence of the first human
species,
about 7,500 generations
since the physiologically
modern human saw the light of
day 500 generations ago.
What we call civilization
began 20 generations go.
We learned how to do science and the
Internet became available to most people
only one generation ago.
Today we live in the most prosperous
age humanity has ever experienced.
We have transformed.
There's planets from the composition of
its atmosphere to large scale changes in
its landscape and also in terms
of the other animals in existence.
We light up the night with artificial
stars and put people in a metal box in the
sky. Some have even walked on our moon.
We've got robots and other planets.
We've looked deep into the past of
the universe with mechanical eyes.
Our knowledge and our way of acquiring
and storing more of it has exploded.
The average high school student today
knows more about the universe than a
scholar a few centuries ago.
Humans dominate this panic.
Even if our rule is very fragile,
we are still not that different from
our ancestors at 70,000 years ago,
but your lifestyle has existed for less
than 0.001% of human history from here
on. There's no saying what the future
holds for. We're building a skyscraper,
but we're not sure if it's standing on
a solid foundation or if we're building
it on quicksand.
Let's leave it with that for now.
The next time you miss your train,
your burger is not hot enough
or someone cuts in line.
Remember how special
there's up human world is?
Maybe it's not worth being upset
about all those little things.
This video was supported by
audible.com/nutshell and the making of it.
We use the book Sapiens,
a brief history of humankind
as one of the major sources.
If you want to get to it or any
other book for free and supporters,
go to audible.com/nutshell
and get a free 30 day trial.
It's so hard to read books
when you have the Internet,
so we can at least listen to them.
In general.
We listened to a lot of audio
books while designing our videos,
so we can highly recommend audible.
Okay.
This was our first take on
making a history related video.
We'd love to make much more of them,
but they take even more
time than our average video,
so we might do three or four a year.
Your feedback's very welcome here.
Thank you so much for watching and
if you want to support us directly,
you can do so on Patriot. It really
helps us out. You think about it here,
or more videos if you
need more distraction.